In storyboard,
Apple refers to a transition between
view controllers as a segue.
These segues are depicted using this
gray arrow that's interrupted
by this circular icon.
You can see a lot of segues and
storyboard for
this make your own adventure app.
Which you'll see a lot more of if
you stick around for lesson 5.
Here on the roll the dice method of our
role view controller dot swift file,
we saw how to present view
controller's programatically.
Now we're going to move onto a second
way of presenting view controllers,
by combining code with
a storyboard Segway.
Now, I don't want any tears, but
first we have to delete all of the code
code in our roll the dice method.
Back in storyboard we're going
to open up our pop up menu for
the role view controller.
And under triggered segues we're going
to drag this manual segue to the dice
view controller.
Here we have a few options for
the segue.
I'm going to choose modal here.
But we'll talk more about the push and
custom options when we get
into the navigation lesson.
Next we need to set the storyboard
identifier for our segue.
So let's close this outline view and
open up the utilities pane and
then if we click on the segue we can
see in the attributes of inspector
where we can set
the storyboard identifier.
So we'll call it roll dice.
Now we have our segue from storyboard.
But we need to write
the code that calls it.
We want the segue to happen
when the dice is rolled.
So we go into the rollTheDice method
in our RollViewController.swift file.
Here we're going to invoke the method
performSegueWithIdentifier.
And our identifier,
of course, is rollDice, and
our sender is self okay let's run it and
see what happens when we roll the dice.
You can see that a new view is
appearing but other was no dice.
Why would that be?
Well we never set their values.
And in fact our first view controller
never even had a reference to the dice
view controller.
Let alone the dice.
So how are we going to
set those dice values.
Let's leave that question open for
now and posture review the steps for
creating the segway.